foreign
and welcome to this video on top 5 cyber
security rules salary and certification
for 2023 by simply learn in this video
we will clear your doubt regarding the
best roles salaries and certification
you can choose to enter or Advance your
career in cyber security but before we
begin if you enjoy watching these type
of videos and find them interesting then
subscribe to our YouTube channel as we
bring you the best videos there also hit
the Bell icon to never miss any update
from Simply learn so let's get started
now let's dive deep into details of the
top 5 cyber security rules salary and
certification in 2023 so first we will
see introduction to cyber security and
after that we will proceed to top 5
cyber security career salaries and
certification the global cyber security
Market is projected to reach 202 billion
by 2023 and more than 1 million cyber
security jobs will be available however
it is estimated that less than 400 000
cyber Security Professionals will be
trained by then with an expected
industry growth rate of 11 in 2023 and
20 in 2025 cyber Security offers a
fast-paced career with a median salary
of 81 000. so in today's interconnected
World cyber attacks occurs every 39
seconds with an average of 2244 daily
attacks the increasing frequency of
these attacks highlights the critical
need for cyber security professional who
can protect Network and computer system
from unauthorized access and Safeguard
your valuable data cyber security is a
growing industry that offers a range of
opportunities at a different skills
level
entry level positions require a high
school diploma or equivalent mid-level
positions often require an associate
degree and advanced level positions
typically require a bachelor degree so
let's explore the top five cyber
security careers for 2023
so at number 5 we have penetration
tester ethical hacker
so we encounter the interviewing role of
a penetration tester or a ethical Texas
these Odysseus professionals specialize
in identifying vulnerabilities within
systems networks and applications they
are thickly exploit these weaknesses to
provide valuable insights and
recommendations for robust security
fortification
this career path calls for a strong
command of cyber security principles
knowledge of network protocols hands-on
experience with penetration testing
tools and certification like offensive
security certified professional oscp or
certified ethical hacker CES embarking
on this thrilling Journey can lead to a
rewarding and impactful career in cyber
security the average salary for pen
institution tester in the U.S is around
91 000 and in India 5 lakh banana so
moving forward at the number four we
have malware analyst our fourth career
choice is the malware analyst these
professionally specialize and identify
and examine cyber threats such as
viruses bombs boards androgens they
develop malware protection tools analyze
ethics patterns and creative strategies
to mitigate future risk a strong
background in computer science reverse
engineering skills and knowledge of
malware analysis tools are necessary for
this role the offensive security
certified professional oscp offered by
offensive security and cissp certified
information system security professional
certification offered by ISC the average
annual salary for a malware analyst in
United States is 86 000 per dollar and
in India is 5 lakh per annum and with
experience changes to 8 lakh per annum
in third position we have the cyber
security engineer these professionals
plan security measures to protect
organizers from cyber attacks design
cyber security platform and collaborate
with other teams to maintain overall
security a degree in information
technology or computer science along
with networking skills and knowledge of
programming languages is essential for
this role certifications such as
certified ethical hacker CH and com Tia
Security Plus can enhance your
credential the average annual salary for
cyber security engineer in United States
is around 125 000 and in India is six
like per annum an increase with
experience so at number two we have
security architect
these professional design robot security
structure to prevent malware attacks
perform well limited tests and provide
technical assistance to security teams a
degree in computer science or
information technology along with skills
in risk management and network Hardware
configuration and security program
certification such as com Tia Security
Plus and cisp can boost your career as
security architect the average annual
salary for security architect is
125 000 and in India is 24 lakh per
annum and increases as per the
experience and at the top at the number
one on the list is Chief Information
Security Officer or cisf the senior
level role is responsible for ensuring
the complete safety of information
within an organization ciso develop and
maintain Information Security Programs
interact with stakeholders and addresses
security concern a computer science
degree nmba and relevant certifications
such as certified information security
manager cism and certified information
system security professional C issb are
preferred for this rule the average
annual salary for cyber security for
ciso in the United States is 166 000 and
in India the average annual salary is
35.7 lakh per annum
so these are just a few of many exciting
cyber security careers available in 2023
with the increasing demand for cyber
security profession now is a great time
to consider a career in this field
whether you are just starting out or
looking to advance your career simply
lens has you got you covered with our
postgraduate program in cyber security
in collaboration with MIT Sportsman this
is designed to equipment skills required
to become an expert in the rapidly
growing field of cyber security the
cyber security program aims to help you
stay ahead of all the latest cyber
security Trends key features of these
programs are simply learn postgraduate
certificate master classes from MIT
faculty featuring modules from mid-scc
and EC Council access to cehk 25 plus
Hands-On projects and many more this
cyber security certification program
begins with introductory level skills
and then progresses to advance your
career cyber security Technologies these
programs cover all the essential skills
you will need to government expert in
the field of cyber security this cyber
security is one of the top concern of
business today in any industry from
securing data to anticipacing cyber
attacks and placing enterprise-wide
safeguards to prevent them employers
worldwide are increasingly looking for
qualified cyber security professional to
join them so what are you waiting for
find the course link mentioned in the
description box below and enroll now
today thank you for joining us today I
repeat and remember to stay safe and
secure in the digital world thank you
and keep learning staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign